Dillon is in Bowling Green hi Dillon
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
Kay how are you today
better than I deserve sir what's up oh
yes sir I was wanting to know like the
quickest sense how to get out of debt
okay well what we suggest folks do how
much dad have you got a roughly around
13,000 okay and what is your income
23,000 a year okay how old are you 19 no
what what do you do I work at a car wash
okay what are your career plans for so
far I was taking college but after my
first semester I actually wanted to go
into real estate okay so you're getting
your real estate license yes sir
okay cool very cool all right well I
mean that there's kind of two numbers
Dillon that we look at and we call it
the shovel to hole ratio and the shovel
is your income versus the hole is your
outgo your your your you know what
you're spending to eat and then how much
debt you have okay so you have $13,000
hole that you're in what do you owe that
money on ten thousand of it is for auto
loans and sixteen hundred a hundred of
it is for a credit line loan and then
the other fifteen hundred to two
thousand for another auto loan okay so
why do you have two car loans
I had a car loan that was in twenty five
point nine percent interest and they was
charging me too much so I'll let it go
back and then I end up getting in
another car loan here recently okay
why did you not have a car at all yes I
didn't have a car at all and they was
trying to towards me that was charging
me like
three times as much as what the car was
worth and I couldn't afford it
don't you okay and so you said you're
making how much money roughly I make
around 450 a week mm-hmm okay
and that's only 3,000 a year okay all
right and mmm and you think you're and
you're--you said you're 19 yes sir okay
cool well what I would suggest you do is
it's just to increase your income by
increasing your hours doing something
and get these debts cleaned up as fast
as possible as you already know real
estate is straight Commission and at
your age it's going to be a little
tougher because it's very tough to
talking some forty-five-year-old into
buying a house from a 19 year old you
can be done I did and I had a real
estate license when I turned 18 and I
sold my first house when I was 18 years
old so you can do that it can happen but
it's harder to have credibility with
folks on a purchase of that size when
you're younger again I'm gonna saying
don't do it but I'm saying that is a
that is a challenge you're gonna have to
overcome do you agree yes okay and so
it's going to be your level of maturity
how you dress how you carry yourself the
words you use the habits you avoid you
know you don't smoke in front of clients
you don't go in there you know dress
crazy you know you dress conservatively
the type of car you drive all of that is
it's gonna you're gonna have to be
mature beyond your years to have
credibility and I I did do that when I
was your age selling real estate so it
can be done and so you're choosing that
instead of college what were you
studying in college I was going to do so
sociology listen being like I guess Serb
not like I forgot a social worker and
things like that hmm
okay and what was drawing you to that
I just like kids and I've been through a
lot myself as a child and I know what
it's like for young ones to like go
through that those kind of things don't
you okay and I just want to change the
world you know and do better things for
the world good for you good for you well
I think that might be a good ministry
for you at your local church to work
with kids may be in foster programs and
stuff like that there'd be a lot of ways
you could be a big brother in a sense to
those guys as a ministry as far as your
career goes I like what you're doing I
want to help you out with that I'm going
to send you through our class on how to
handle money Financial Peace University
have you heard us talk about that uh yes
there okay would you like to go through
for free yes there all right you hold on
we'll get you signed up for that and
that can give you a framework for making
some of these decisions so very very
well done good job